these days were divided into blue
bubbles and green bubbles yes I'm
talking about the serious serious
problem of messaging color bubbles and
if you don't have an iPhone you probably
have no idea what I'm talking about
right now see in your iPhone messages
app if you're messaging with someone
else who has an iPhone you're
communicating via iMessage and your
messages will appear in a blue bubble if
they're on an Android phone or heaven
forbid an old Blackberry or flip phone
you're communicating via the cellular
networks SMS text messaging your
outgoing messages or texts on your
iPhone appear in a green bubble and oh
boy do some iPhone people hate green
messages just look at these tweets just
a tad extreme but I get the frustration
blue bubble chats are just better you
get those three little dots to tell if
somebody's typing the delivered and read
notifications group chats are more
seamless and you can send doodles or
money there's some possible good news on
the horizon Android phone makers and
cellular carriers have started using
rich communication services or RCS which
brings the best of messaging apps like
iMessage or whatsapp to cross operating
system texting it's faster supports read
receipts and has typing indicators Apple
hasn't adopted it yet but if it does it
could solve all those green bubble
problems
for the last week though I've lived in
this hell as a green bubble person yes I
switched to the pixel three and well my
family almost fell apart but along the
way I found out three important things
for those iPhone users dealing with
green bubble friends tip 1 turn on group
MMS make sure group MMS messages is
turned on under settings messages group
MMS this should ensure that all photo
and video messages appear to everyone at
the same time and in the same chain this
should mean no multiple messaging chains
tip 2 over communicate ask your green
bubble friends things like are you
getting this or even please confirm the
receipt of this message it may sound
crazy but sometimes messages from recent
iPhone to Android converts can get lost
tip 3 whatsapp or signal just switch to
a better messaging app Facebook owned
whatsapp is fast has end-to-end
encryption plus read receipts and all
that other fun stuff and so far no ads
but if you're sick of Facebook's abrupt
product changes and money-making schemes
go with signal you can set messages to
expire after a certain amount of time
and all messages are encrypted and want
to know the best part about signal all
the bubbles default to blue so you never
have to see green again
[Music]